Cardinal George Pell is the most senior
member of the Catholic Church to be
found guilty of child sex offenses after
the 12 members of a jury in Melbourne
believed the word of a victim over that
of the former Archbishop but lawyers for
the 78 year old said the jury's verdict
was unreasonable and argued the defense
was blocked from showing a video in
their closing argument Louise Milligan
who has written a book about the
Cardinal knows one of his victims this
has been an enormous ly difficult
process for all of the people who made
complaints to come forward and to go
through you know being cross-examined at
trial about something that happened when
they were children it's stressful and no
matter what happens in this appeal in
this judgement no one's going to be
celebrating Pal was a priest in rural
Australia who rose to become Archbishop
of Melbourne and then Sydney as
Australia's most senior Catholic he
oversaw the church's response to
accusations of child abuse by others
when a major inquiry was held looking
into that he had to defend what many saw
as a cover-up but it didn't slow his
career by then Pell was a cardinal at
the Vatican in charge of the church's
finances and close to the Pope that life
ended though when Pell was personally
accused of sexual abuse I'm innocent of
these charges they are false Pell 6 year
prison term was the combined sentence
for sexually abusing two
thirteen-year-old choir boys in a
Melbourne Cathedral his conviction sent
shockwaves through the Catholic Church
which was already dealing with a torrent
of sex abuse scandals carried out by
clerics in positions of power I think
they're in denial about everything
that's happened to George Pell and I
think that if the spotlight is ever off
them they will continue to deny
obfuscate use their power use their
money to actually stop individuals
coming out into the public and
I'm accountable three court of appeal
judges have been considering whether pel
was wrongly convicted or not and will
hand down their ruling later
Victoria Gaytan be al-jazeera